-Our first guest tonight
is a world wrestling
entertainment superstar
and 16-time world champion.
He's also a talented actor
you know from "Trainwreck,"
"Blockers," and the
"Fast & Furious" franchise.
He stars in "Peacemaker,"
which is streaming
on HBO Max January 13th.
Let's take a look.
-♪ I could've cried ♪
♪ I could've cried ♪
♪♪
♪ When she said ♪
♪ I don't love you anymore ♪
Hey, I got to thank you
for tonight.
-Please welcome back to the
show our friend John Cena.
How are you, John?
-The beliked Seth Meyers.
Beloved, in my book.
I'm very well.
How are you, sir?
-I'm very well.
Thanks for the upgrade.
I think that the difference
between that clip
and the last clip we showed
when you came on
is maybe the most massive
switch of clips.
Last time, you were jumping
through windows
and, now, we have you dancing
in your tighty-whities.
Beautifully done.
Is that choreographed,
or is that all John Cena?
-That's interpretive dance.
-[ Laughs ]
-I didn't think anybody was
rolling on that
and, now, it's for the world
to see on HBO Max
this Thursday, yeah.
So that's out there.
It's a brave show.
-It's very authentic,
very personal, very beautiful.
-It's a whole lot.
It's a whole lot of Peace.
No, I mean, you know,
depending on what you see,
depending on what you see.
-Now, you're wearing
the costume, John,
but we do not see the helmet,
the iconic helmet,
because you lost it
last evening.
-That son of a bitch Fallon.
-Yep.
-I lost it in a sucker's bet.
We play games all the time
and I always win
and there's no stakes,
so I go in pretty much
undefeated
and I bet that he had
to frost his tips
and I bet him
the Peacemaker helmet
and, yeah,
I lost the Peacemaker helmet,
that I don't own,
to Jimmy Fallon in a sucker bet.
That son of a bitch.
-I mean, you think the stakes
were high for you.
Here I am, watching it last
night, thinking, "I can't wait.
I get to have the helmet guy
on my show."
Nothing.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, and, now, you just got
a guy with blue gloves, yeah.
Such a letdown.
So sorry.
-This is so fun.
Peacemaker was such a fun
character to play for you,
for me to watch,
in "Suicide Squad"
and, now, right after, we get
to see it in its own show.
A different kind of superhero,
sort of damaged,
sort of raunchy,
sort of crass and arrogant
and all things that, I think,
if we actually had superheroes,
we would probably see a lot more
than maybe the superheroes
we've been fed over the years.
-So, hero is virtue.
Superhero is super virtue.
Peacemaker is a guy
who kills for peace
and he's really good
at what he does
and he's really, really flawed.
And I think that's
when you say like,
"If we could see all those
things in superheroes,
it would probably be
more authentic."
That's because we're all human.
Superheroes are
all super virtuous.
Peacemaker is jealous
of all these superheroes.
There was an Aquaman clip
that went viral,
that Peacemaker released,
Peacemaker's thoughts
on Aquaman,
and it just goes to show
that he's like,
jealous of real superheroes.
And I think that makes
for an awesome, funny journey.
We have a wonderful cast
to surround Peacemaker
and it kind of explores the fact
that this guy,
with this set of skills,
thinks he's a superhero,
but his perspective on life
may be a little bit upside-down.
-Is there something --
It must feel similar, at times,
the performative nature of what
you're doing with Peacemaker,
compared to your, you know,
long and illustrious career
in WWE.
I mean, there is a cinematic
universe to the WWE.
There is the building
of heroes and villains.
I mean, did you feel
that parallel
when you entered
the superhero world?
-Kind of,
but it was the opposite.
So, in WWE, the John Cena
character is one of virtue,
one of hard work,
loyalty, respect,
never giving up, persistence,
always, even when your back
is against the wall,
trying to do
the morally right thing.
So this one was easy.
I would just have to say like,
"Okay, what I do in WWE?"
Do the opposite of that
and add some profanity
and that's Peacemaker.
-You know, obviously, now,
we've come to
not be surprised by the
comedic chops you've shown
in things like "Trainwreck"
and things like "Blockers."
Were you happy when you first
got that chance to do it?
Were you pleased with how easy
it came to you?
-So, man, thank you very much
for the flattery.
You have to remember,
in those films,
in any forum I do comedy in,
I want to be able to surround
myself with really funny people
and funny people know how
to draw the funny out of others,
even if it's at their expense,
which I also don't mind,
which makes me
a nice target for comedy.
But I think,
in all those circumstances,
especially starting
with "Trainwreck,"
you know, Judd casts amazingly
and Amy was so giving
and provided
such a great environment.
I think it's just, for me,
it's been great to surround
myself with funny people
and allow them to just tee off
and then just kind of be present
to see what's going on.
-One of your costars is one
of our favorite on this show,
Danielle Brooks.
-Oh, dude, that's great.
-I need to ask --
have you seen Danielle
make balloon animals yet?
-I haven't.
What is that process all about?
-I would just say ask Danielle
to make you a balloon animal
and just know
that you haven't lived yet.
You haven't lived yet.
-Ah!
With someone with an incredible
lust for life,
I can't wait to see
these balloon animals.
-I learned --
I heard, I should say --
that you had to learn
some sword skills for the show.
Did you take to the sword?
-It took a while
to take to the sword.
You see a lot of sword
in the "Suicide Squad."
You pretty much see me dancing
with my sword in "Peacemaker."
-[ Laughs ]
-There's a lot of weaponry.
There's a lot of weaponry mixed
with vulgarity in "Peacemaker"
and you'll probably see my sword
more than a sword.
I think we have a chain saw
in there, somewhere.
Yeah, there's a lot of stuff.
There's a lot of stuff.
-A lot of sharp edges.
Now, this is something
that I was surprised to hear,
but maybe shame on me
for being surprised.
You're a man who contains
multitudes.
-[ Laughs ]
-Is it true that you are also,
John Cena is a man who's happy
to walk into an antique shop?
-Oh, yeah, I love antiques.
Like, man, I really do.
I love going antiquing.
I love trying to find out the
story behind all these objects.
I don't necessarily --
Although I love finding value
and look for bargains,
it's more the story
and the object
that I find really exciting.
And I just, I don't know,
there's something about
an object with pedigree,
an object with a story.
I don't know.
Maybe it's the imagination,
but, yes, I do absolutely
love antiquing.
You can tell that this
struck a nerve.
I got the spirit fingers.
[ Laughter ]
Antiquing! Ooh!
-I've never seen you
like this, John.
[ Laughter ]
Now, I'm not surprised
to hear that,
in your younger days,
you were a bouncer.
I think anyone would be able
to track that
as maybe a good first job
for a young John Cena.
But will you please tell
the story about being next
to a pizza shop
and a terrible mistake
they made,
not known John Cena
was working next door.
-So I was also,
like Swayze in "Roadhouse,"
I was the bouncer
that didn't drink.
-Okay.
-It's much more
of a cooler will, yeah.
I was more Sam Elliott
than Swayze, though.
The pizza pizza place offered
free pizza,
if you could eat a full pizza,
and it was Chicago
deep dish-style.
But I was broke and sober
at 2:00 am
and I literally just kept
eating pizza and eating pizza
and it was like
an achievement for them
and they would put
a pizza dish on the wall
with your name on it.
And, by the time I had
multiple pans on the wall,
the guy realized he was getting
killed on product
and on process
because he's losing a pizza pan
every time I eat one.
-[ Laughs ]
-Finally, he was just like,
"Dude,
you don't have to eat the pie.
Come over after work for a few
slices and we got you."
That place was Zeppe's pizza,
that eventually closed.
I'm not saying I had anything
to do with it,
but I probably didn't help
their bottom line
or their profit-loss statement.
-That's true. But, at least,
I think they would --
In the way that antiques
have a great story,
at least, they have one to share
about a young John Cena
putting them out of business.
-Somewhere, there's two or three
Zeppe's pizza trays
with "John Cena," the date,
my weight, and "I did it."
Yeah, so those
are floating around.
Maybe, one of these days,
at one of these flea markets.
-Thanks for being here.
You know what I'm going
to actually look for
at an antique shop
is that helmet
you lost to Fallon
because you know Fallon
sold it, first thing.
-Dude, he couldn't --
He thought I took it with him
when I left the show
and I totally gave it to him
and he wanted to use it
as a prop for his next skit
and he's like, "If Cena took it,
I'm going to be so pissed,"
and the lady's like,
"No, here it is.
It's really yours."
-Yeah, I would've loved
to have seen what happened
when Jimmy Fallon was so pissed
with John Cena.
[ Laughs ]
-I would've loved to have seen
how that turned out.
[ Laughing ]
-Wow, man, yeah.
-Hey, congrats on the show.
I've watched the first one.
It's so much fun.
You were so right
about how great the cast is
and I can't wait to see more.
Thanks for being here, John.
-As always, thank you.
-John Cena, everybody.
"Peacemaker" is streaming
on HBO Max January 13th.
We'll be right back.